this is vladivostok the largest russian
city on the pacific ocean
vladivostok is home to a number of
unique attractions including one of the
country's only two funiculars
commissioned as part of a 1959 plan to
build soviet san francisco
impressive bridges built for the 2012
apex summit
and one of the world's largest aquariums
but perhaps its most unusual attraction
is something you won't find listed on
any travel guide
repair korea an exclusively north korean
contractor specializing in home repair
and renovation
its website translated here to english
acknowledges your skepticism
some people think you shouldn't invite
koreans to repair your apartment
but reassures you that quote unlike
spoiled russian specialists koreans work
extremely professionally accurately and
in full compliance with the world
quality standards
but don't assume north korean builders
are confined to any one construction
niche
others helped build the world cup
stadium in st petersburg and apartment
buildings in moscow
neither do they work only in russia
after the u.s state department commended
the country of kuwait for cutting ties
with north korea kuwait responded with
confusion saying there are no plans to
expel north korean laborers and kuwait
has never done so
the regime collects the vast majority of
these wages while recipient nations get
access to cheap hard-working labor
this trade is often cited as proof that
sanctions don't work it seems there's
always a way around them
after the un demanded that countries
expel north korean workers in 2017 for
instance russia simply reissued them
tourist and student visas
the country is also responsible for
countless hacking campaigns ransomware
attacks the production of counterfeits
and a dozen other illicit odd jobs
but in fact the opposite
the extreme length that goes to evade
sanctions even when the payoff is
relatively small suggests they do have a
powerful effect
and yet there hasn't been any meaningful
diplomatic progress in
decades so why do sanctions bring iran
to the negotiating table but not north
korea
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
get both and watch the bonus video that
accompanies this one for just 15 bucks a
year
north korea has sought nuclear weapons
with varying degrees of urgency for its
entire existence
in 1959 just six years after the end of
the korean war the soviet union agreed
to build it a reactor though not without
conditions
the soviets pressured them to sign the
non-proliferation treaty which they
finally did in 1985
but inconsistencies emerged almost
immediately
after signing the treaty countries are
required to submit an initial report in
which they declare how much nuclear
material is already in their possession
north korea waited seven years to do so
and international inspectors soon
noticed a discrepancy in the amount of
declared plutonium
it then refused to allow further
inspections withdrew from the treaty and
even neglected its binding commitments
but this was only the first of many
broken promises to come
in 1994 after four months of
negotiations the u.s agreed to give it
two light water reactors and 500 000
tons of fuel oil annually in exchange
for the freezing of its weapons program
then north korea was caught secretly
enriching uranium and according to the
us even admitted to it
a new round of negotiations began in
2003 which appeared to reach a
breakthrough
nuclear facilities were dismantled and
the country was removed from america's
list of state sponsors of terrorism
predictably north korea announced it
would restart its nuclear program
several years later
at this point no doubt remained about
its true intentions dishonesty had been
demonstrated time and time and time
again
perhaps even more worrisome was its long
history of sporadic and dangerous
behavior
this includes multiple attempted
assassinations of the south korean
president airplane bombs the 1968
capture of an american ship and firing
at both military and civilian planes
and when the carrot fails conventional
wisdom would suggest it's time for the
stick
sanctions were the only option left it
seemed for a country that couldn't be
trusted
over time they expanded from covering
military equipment to travel luxury
goods raw materials and even food
severely restricting even basic
humanitarian aid
but just as negotiation appeared less
and less effective over time sanctions
have now been around long enough to
identify a pattern
they don't work
the problem is not contrary to popular
thinking that sanctions are easily
evaded in 2017 and 18 a decline in trade
led to a 3.5 and 4.1 percent decrease in
its gdp
exports declined by 90 percent in 2018.
of course neither are they perfectly
effective
far from it
there will always be black markets and
someone else with a vested interest in
north korea's continued existence
china for instance supplies its neighbor
with just enough coal oil and food to
prevent its collapse the vacuum of which
would soon be filled by an american ally
this measly income is akin to an
unemployed person recycling bottles and
cans it's not nothing but pretty close
at the scale of a nation
to put things in perspective north
korea's gdp is half that of vermont's
the u.s state with the smallest economy
yet its population is 40 times larger
the problem is that sanctions don't work
as intended they clearly haven't ended
its nuclear program or put an end to
missile tests
the first reason is that the wrong
people are affected
the only group whose suffering might
induce change are elites yet the burden
of sanctions is mostly felt by the
middle class and below
as inflation increases average
working-class households struggle to
maintain the same standard of living
high sanction-driven prices mean that 97
of afghanistan will fall below the
poverty line this year according to a
u.n estimate
when the rich and powerful are affected
they can simply cut back on social
programs to compensate
now you might argue this is how things
are supposed to work
the civilian population puts pressure on
the government and the threat of losing
power encourages it to change course
but this effect is strongest in
democracies which sanctioned countries
are less likely to be
north korea on the other hand goes well
beyond less democratic it's the textbook
example of a country unlikely to
experience political revolution
insulated from the rest of the world in
virtually every respect it can easily
control the narrative blaming higher
prices and lower quality of life on the
enemy
if anything sanctions have the opposite
effect
just as residents of yugoslavia blamed
the un not their own government in the
90s they instill a unifying patriotism
among north koreans
again the net effect of sanctions for
its leaders is unquestionably negative
they lead to malnutrition death disease
population decline and ultimately
economic failure
after the collapse of the soviet union
the regime's closest ally between 600
000 and 1 million koreans died of hunger
while sanctions were not the direct
cause they certainly didn't help
even if you believe these deaths mean
nothing to kim jong-un the axis of evil
label diminishes the country's
legitimacy it desperately wants to be
treated like a normal country
this is evidenced according to many
experts by the continuous cycle of
missile tests which are followed by
demands for negotiation
despite having long ago demonstrated its
nuclear capabilities it's nevertheless
discontent with the status quo
so we're seemingly back to square one
if it wants sanctions lifted why doesn't
it strike a deal
to answer this question try putting
yourself no matter how unnatural it may
feel in the shoes of kim jong-un whose
number one fear is regime change
this deeply held fear is not stalinist
paranoia or an archaic leftover of the
soviet era
kim jong-un has every legitimate reason
to worry
after all none of this is theoretical
libya acceded to u.s demands halting the
development of its nuclear program in
2003.
eight years later the dead body of
muammar gaddafi was on public display
just in case the lesson that an autocrat
should never surrender his weapons of
mass destruction wasn't made clear
enough american officials have since
made repeated unequivocal threats that
the same thing could happen to kim
jong-un
in the lead-up to the 2018 singapore
summit for instance president trump
warned that his north korean counterpart
would suffer the same fate as gaddafi if
a deal wasn't reached
u.s south korean and japanese forces
regularly conduct mock decapitation
drills on its doorstep
and in 2006 former secretary of defense
william perry published an op-ed titled
if necessary strike and destroy
none of this obviously absolves north
korea of any responsibility
its negotiating behavior has ranged from
merely skittish to downright deceitful
but in truth the us has also given it
plenty of genuine reason for skepticism
what the simplistic version of events
suggesting north korea never intended on
following through on its promises from
earlier misses is the lack of american
political continuity
the 1994 agreed framework when north
korea was caught secretly enriching
uranium for example is remembered as a
failure while its actions certainly
violated the spirit of the agreement it
did suspend production of plutonium as
promised which was a significant step in
the right direction
also missing is that the clinton
administration completed a review of u.s
policy on september 15 1999
recommending quote a new comprehensive
and integrated approach to negotiations
but that radical new approach never came
to fruition because george bush won the
presidency 14 months later
bush began his own policy review which
took another year and ended by
effectively suspending the agreed
framework
now the u.s had every right to withdraw
from its side of the agreement after all
north korea had clearly violated it
first
but in doing so it let north korea off
the hook for everything allowing it to
resume production of plutonium
not only did america willfully lose the
little bit of progress it had made it
also permanently diminished the very
currency of negotiations
trust
again blame lies squarely in north
korea's court but one can easily see how
america's actions would inspire less
than supreme confidence in pyongyang
in addition to the lack of political
continuity which leads countries around
the world to doubt america's long-term
commitments and think they can simply
wait it out for a new administration
there's also the issue of funding
presidents can negotiate but only
congress controls the purse
when the two branches disagree
commitments made by the president may be
broken
the other country won't care whose exact
fault it is only that the promise was
broken
another neglected aspect of the agreed
framework were the delays
angry that the u.s was quote rewarding
the enemy with fuel oil and two light
water reactors which cannot be used to
build nuclear weapons congress withheld
funding which led north korea to doubt
its sincerity
a lot has changed in the last 30 some
years
aside from a few brief pauses here and
there north korea has continued
improving its capabilities from
possessing one or two bombs to missile
delivery hydrogen bombs ballistic
missiles and most recently long-range
road mobile ballistic missiles capable
of reaching anywhere on the u.s mainland
and yet the u.s still demands the exact
same thing it did in 1990
complete verifiable and irreversible
denuclearization
its bottom line is that north korea
abandoned 30 years of development
economic sacrifices and likely the only
thing keeping kim jong-un alive
if this was ever a realistic demand it
stopped being one decades ago
each successive american president
arrives fresh in the white house
believing they can be the one to finally
resolve the crisis once and for all
but they soon discover that there are
only two possible pathways
either be forever known as the one to
accept that it's too late that north
korea is and will remain a nuclear power
that there's nothing the u.s can do
about it and risk being perceived as
soft on the enemy of all enemies
or accept nothing less than the only
thing kim jong-un won't ever agree to
complete denuclearization
setting themselves up to fail from the
very beginning
if the goal is merely to punish the
united states has unquestionably
succeeded but more likely having an
effect has been confused with
effectiveness
the irony is that by refusing to accept
even one percent risk america must now
accept much more than one percent risk
the world's most powerful country cannot
cope with the fact that the one country
beyond its control has an economy the
size of mozambique and a leader whose
most discernible personality trait is a
passion for swiss cheese
so accustomed to having the final say
the ability to kill any leader of any
country at any time
the u.s is almost perfectly ill-suited
to deal with a country where such
threats are exactly the cause of angst
and therefore bad behavior in the first
place
so what's the solution and is north
korea an exception or are economic
sanctions vastly overrated
both these questions are the subject of
the bonus video that accompanies this
one on nebula the creator-owned
streaming platform
by signing up for nebula you get access
to a dozen other polymatter bonus videos
and extended content exclusive originals
and for the same low price curiosity
stream
curiosity stream is home to great
documentaries on history science and
technology
another country that struggled under the
weight of u.s sanctions is cuba but the
lack of tourist has turned its natural
environment into an untouched experiment
this documentary explores that dilemma
can cuba keep its beaches pristine or
will it eventually succumb to financial
pressure
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream for
just 15 bucks a year and go watch the
bonus video over on nebula